I love that you guys have kind of been
on like a little World Tour and I have
to say I think malzi has more passport
stamps than I do already
my parents raised me like that so was my
husband was so the same thing for her uh
right now she's not in school so we can
schlep her wherever we want also love
spending time with her so it's cool from
sitting in Mama's lap while she's
glamming it up to front row at her dad's
Joe Bros concert in London malty is
living the dream and that includes
tagging along while Priyanka promotes
her new Prime video Show Citadel
streaming Friday Priyanka you were
quoted as saying look I earned my scars
for this show
even though I should ask
Dad it was a lot of work I mean it won't
lie
Priyanka and Richard Madden play spies
who have their memories erased in the
action thriller produced by Marvel
masterminds the Russo Brothers the
series is reportedly the second most
expensive ever made costing an estimated
200 million and it's already been
renewed for season two we're introduced
to wake up at three o'clock in the
morning and work out that wasn't me
though
[Laughter]
I work out for a couple hours and then
go and fight all day
but it looks good in the end Stanley
Tucci is the man that brings them
together to reignite their Memories the
scope of it the scale of it is enormous
you need to remember the past
I love his baritone voice I'm always
like just keep talking Stanley
everything you know is a lie it's such
an honor talk to you but I want to bring
up so many different roles is there a
character you'd love to play again I
would not play George Harvey again in
The Lovely Bones that was horrible I'm
not gonna hurt you Susie
that is a wonderful movie but it was a
tough experience
I would happily play uh Nigel in The
Devil Wears Prada again that was a
really great experience is there a quote
that surprised you that has like caught
on that people say well gerd your loins
all right everyone gird your loins
[Music]
thank you